2009 10 das erste komplette jahr mit
annegret kramp-karrenbauer als
cdu-vorsitzende und sagen was man so ihr
start verlief ausbaufähig sage ich mal
es ist eine pannenserie die einfach
nicht enden will für den moment um so
lustiger das akh hier jetzt der spd
vorwirft sachen zu fordern die nicht im
koalitionsvertrag stehen exakt dasselbe
macht sie doch ständig als
verteidigungsministerin wenn sie mehr
auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr fordert
oder deutsche flugzeugträger ist klar
deutsche flugzeugträger wie schaffen sie
ja nicht mal einen zu finden der bei der
gorch fock die segel stopft das ist die
realität aber gut immerhin wird der alte
macho verein cdu weiterhin von einer
frau geführt was ja auch nicht
selbstverständlich
trotzdem müssen wir heute feststellen
dass es immer noch frauen gibt die von
bildung ausgeschlossen ist
ja ist doch leider war
sind sie völlig recht zur
geburtstagsparty 70 jahre nato
letzte woche hat angela merkel die
annegret gar nicht mehr mitgenommen ist
kein witz fast alle anderen
regierungschefs hatten ihre
verteidigungsminister dabei irgendwas
ist also zerbrochen zwischen diesen
beiden frauen und dabei fing es so schön
an vor einem jahr aber dann hat die hkk
in der morgenlage im kanzleramt so
derartig sowie ideen gehabt dass die
merkel gesagt hat kommen die kleine
praktikanten aus dem saarland die lassen
wir es mal 500 mal das grundgesetz
kopieren die soll mal schön
regierungsrechner von windows 95 windows
98 updaten oder merkels persönliches
altglas zum container bringen oder fürs
umweltministerium so ein album basteln
mit allen wichtigen blättern des waldes
und wenn im kanzleramt besuch kommt von
marco dann schickt merkel sie natürlich
auf ihr zimmer bald besser ist weiß
besser
[Applaus]
dieses macht gekommen ja irgendwie
schade
überlegen sie mal auf dem ersten
parteitag ihrem ersten parteitag ein
chefin musste die hkk direkt mit
rücktritt drohen um ihre rest autorität
noch zu retten
trotzdem verleihen wir den vollpfosten
ganz bewusst heute nicht ihr sondern dem
möchtegern putschisten friedrich merz
schauen sie mal hier sogar mit original
h insel vorne
ja das ist der posten in der umfaller
edition denn immer wenn es ernst wird
fällt unser fritz um
abgesehen davon hat die partei der
beiden natürlich ganz andere sorgen und
zwar katastrophale umfragewerte bei
jungen wählern
das sieht nicht gut aus die union
versteht die jungen einfach nicht mehr
das wissen wir spätestens seit der herr
rieso die cdu zerstören wollte wir
erinnern uns ja beziehungsweise seit ein
gewisser philipp am tor
tragischerweise darauf geantwortet hat
wieso du alter zerstöre zerstörung der
cdu ja selber model filippa mtor der
einzige jugendliche der welt der beim
thema jugendsprache sogar vom zdf noch
was lernen kann
insgesamt unfassbar und souveräne
reaktion der cdu friesland auch dieser
fresche influenza total unbeholfen ende
ich möchte davon nichts mehr hören total
unbeholfen
ja sagt wohlgemerkt der mann der sich
nach insgesamt zwei tweets in sechs
monaten bei twitter wieder abgemeldet
hat dann musste der horst ich wieder
hinlegen so weite teile der union
versuchen gerade immer noch das phänomen
junge menschen zu verstehen
sie sind ratlos was finden die bloß an
diesem riesen herzlich willkommen zu
[Musik]
ehrlich perfekt um
wer nicht färbt bleibt dumm wie war das
rätsel politisierte jugend reden wir
darüber mit birte schneider von der
frauen union böblingen
sie hat heute ihren 16-jährigen sohn
konstantin mitgebracht der freut sich
riesig hier zurzeit frau schneider hat
die cdu sich von den jungen menschen
entfremdet
ich bitte sie ja welche gut vielleicht
durch die cdu heute nicht mehr ganz so
hip und cool wie noch zu meiner jugend
kinder rosam wird krachen lassen
früher in böblingen ich weiß noch einmal
haben wir auf meine mädchen gymnasium
sogar die vermot ag geschwänzt und sind
einfach zu einer demo gange einfach so
ja das war eine demonstration für franz
josef strauß
aber was mit dem constantin los ich
keine ahnung von morgens bis abends
redet der jungen nur noch übers wetter
klima sag ich doch klima hier gräbt hat
da und immer auf krawall früher wenn ich
in der adventszeit gesagt ab konnte marc
schmidt am amazonas
da ging aber ein strahlen über das
kleine dick sich
und heute nichts tote augen von zuviel
internet seit 12 jahren darf ich nicht
mal mehr seine bettwäsche waschen und
das sagt mir nicht warum
konstantin warum darf der die mama
netter niewisch bitte sage ganz ehrlich
diese aggressivität da toren dieser
friday kinder das geht überhaupt nicht
das ist unsere zukunft und nicht die der
erwachsenen menschen die jetzt auch
schon irgendwann sterben halt gut wo er
recht hat meine klar sind die sauer weil
die groko zu wenig macht für klimaschutz
die sind doch alle dieser kreta hörig
wir früher habe auch geschwärmt aber
dann wenigstens für rock stars wie katja
ebstein oder
oder die winkel juli haben es die auch
für ich verstehe ihn nicht mehr das
ganze frühjahr hat der kunst stand die
nur von artikel 13 schwätzt und
irgendwas mit zensur und download upload
schilter ja herr goethe bei der
waschmaschine ist halt mal bei upload
fehlt doch verkalkt
es ist doch kein weltuntergang und was
diese netzthemen angeht da halte ich es
ganz mit unserer frau bundeskanzlerin
wir müssen erstmal wissen selber als
politiker was passiert da wir sind ja
alle auch nicht in dem internet
aufgewachsen sind nicht aufgewachsen in
diesem internet sondern in böblingen ja
ich kann den frust seiner generation
schon nachvollziehen wenn ich sehe was
allein in rente mit 63 oder die
bekloppte mütter rente geballert wird
und wie wenig im vergleich in den
digital packt sie unsere schule da ist
was dran
aber ich will mich jetzt noch einen
streiten sich auf weihnachten
und irgendwann soll man wahrscheinlich
auch loslassen oder sie könnte ich
loslassen
das ist ganz wichtig ich musste es als
mutter schlichtweg respektieren dass
mein constantin eigene ideen hat eigene
träume und ja auch das war ein stück
weit erwachsene partner kunstlied sie
denn ist aus dem fernseher
absolut würde lothar schneider vergangen
und herren
wir sind was haben die spd und 2019
gemeinsam richtig weiter gehen so
langsam zu ende
aber wie sie wissen hat in dieser
sendung traditionell keinen platz
anders als in der ard da lassen sogar
hochseriöse nachrichtensprecherin ihrer
schadensfall hemmungslos freien lauf
nach dem schlechten abschneiden der spd
bei der europawahl vizefraktionschef
finalist nun früher einer neuwahl
insbesondere klar darüber kann ich nicht
lahm
und wo wir gerade beim bremsen sie sieht
ihn aber auch ähnlich
wo wir gerade bei angela nahles sind
noch ein kleiner tipp liebe spd wenn ihr
das nächste mal eure führungsspitze
weggemobbt fraß auch einfach mal vorher
überhaupt noch ein depp gibt er den
schwan job machen will man seinen mann
nämlich mit walter saskia es genial oder
wie auch immer eure neuen der heißen
hier triumphaler einzug ins
willy-brandt-haus
spd-generalsekretär lars klingbeil
begrüßt seine neue chefin von einem
kolleginnen und kollegen im haus
herziges bekommen
habe ich das richtig verstanden
alle mitarbeiter des willy brandt hauses
legen zusammen und das ergebnis ist
dieser zwang stellt straße 30 19
wenn man mehr muss man über die spd echt
nicht mehr wissen beim parteitag haben
die sozis jetzt ihre ideen
aufgeschrieben 12 euro mindestlohn
kindergrundsicherung lauter tolle sachen
denen der groko gar nicht kommen können
es gibt also jetzt offiziell zwei spd
ist ja und zwar die gute die wir in zwei
jahren wählen sollen und die böse die
die nächsten zwei jahren mitregiert mit
anderen worten herzlichen glückwunsch
zum schizophrenie vollpfosten liebe
genossen und genießen und macht mal
wieder ganz genau so weiter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sag mal spd wie lange bist du schon
geisel der union
jede wahl tut
bist du zweistellig ja dann hast du
schon
doch jetzt
treu
wieder von 30 prozent
[Musik]
da frau
nicht nur
[Musik]
die drogen im optimales bis sie sagte
sie und sei darauf auch nur stumm
doch so sind landen
eure polit das 2
[Musik]
wir schlagen
nicht mal
[Musik]
bis märz ist ganz übernehmen
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liegt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller